[MUSIC]
Today is the day to defeat
Xana and get her back to her last seat.
Well, the resentment of having Kai
killed The resentment of
having Masaki, who was found,
please talk to me here
[music] I
wonder if it's a magic stone
[applause]
Iida has an interesting way of fighting yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Bach yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah tan [music] Don't do it hard That's my line I'm
sorry but I won't return the magic stones I'll take back everything you have
Why are you so
obsessed with the subject that you want to suffer the misfortune
of a
human being?
I'm sure you're just accepting it, but
what do you know about me
?